hey what's up y'all i'm dara renee and i
play courtney green
hey i'm matt cornett and i play ej
caswell hi
i'm frankie rodriguez and i play carlos
hi i'm joe sarafini and i play seb
matthew smith
hi my name is sophia wiley and i play
gina porter hey i'm larry saperstein and
i play big red hi
i'm julia lester and i play ashlynn hey
i'm joshua vebasset and i play ricky in
high school musical the musical the
series
we are here today with buzzfeed to play
a game of would you rather so buckle up
all right question number one would you
rather forget all your lines while on
stage
or perform in front of a huge audience
in your underwear
like i've had to do shirtless scenes so
like i feel like i've gotten over that
fear but for getting your minds on stage
is probably the most terrifying
that is forgetting yeah forgetting your
lines on stage is literally a nightmare
i've had so many times and it's
the worst nightmare i think i've ever
had uh it's one of my big fears of
showing up to work without knowing my
lines so
i'm i'm gonna go with performing in my
underwear both
are very bad options i mean forget all
my lines i can improv because i know the
scene so i'm gonna just
now my she's right she's right here
i agree i might have to say underwear
you know you could always sort of run
off stage and and find some clothes but
if i forgot my lines i forgot my lines
and there's kind of no coming back from
that
as much as i would hate to be in front
of an audience in my underwear i feel
like
it might make more sense they could just
think it's part of the show
i'll say underwear would you rather be
cast as your enemies love interest
or cast as your best friend's nemesis oh
best friend best friend's nemesis i
think it's so much fun
that's what matt and i are doing now
literally i think it's so much fun to
get to hate your best friend
like like it's great i agree that's a
hard one
because like i love the love hate like
thing like i love the books about that
but um i guess in real life it would not
be too fun so i'm gonna say
best friends nemesis like y'all oh best
friends nemesis
best friends nemesis for sure that would
be so fun
yeah i think my best friend's nemesis i
feel like that'd be
really fun in season one gina was not
really anyone's friend
but in real life sophia wiley was our
best friend very true
would you rather only be able to watch
movies starring
zac efron or only be able to listen to
music
sung by olivia rodrigo that's tricky i
would probably do
uh olivia rodrigo i just thought she
could make so many more songs and
you know that'll be at least diversity
then there's only so many
movies you know i'm a big fan of zac
efron but i uh
just learned that my top two listened to
artists of 2021
uh on apple music are olivia rodrigo and
joshua bassett so
i think i'm gonna have to go to uh be
able to listen to music sung by olivia
rodriguez
i think i'm gonna say that too no shade
to zac efron
some of his movies would scare me a
little bit like the one where he was um
yeah you're right i don't wanna watch
that one again he played that part a
little too well hold on
i think only listen to music sung by
olivia because that's what i do anyways
i was literally gonna say the same thing
but i do both of these so do you see the
inner conflict there should just be a
third button saying both because i agree
frankie i do the same
but i'm gonna go olivia rodrigo just
because she can constantly put out new
music so i'll never get bored
this is a no-brainer for me as much as i
love both of them
i would only be able to listen to music
sung by olivia rodrigo
i completely agree would you rather be
accepted into your dream school and
never get to see your friends or totally
give up on your dream and see your
friends
every day i was thinking i would go to
my dream school
and make new friends dang joe you said
bye
i don't want to go to school i would
rather never be able to see my friends
if my friends were really my friends and
getting to my dream school they'd be
full supportive you'd be able to make
new friends at your
dream school but then because they're
your friends would you never get to see
them again
yeah we gotta go into the technicalities
here with buzzfeed there's a couple
details work out
i know i would say dream school because
i mean like you got to go after your
dreams no matter what and your friends
will support you no matter what yes
i agree like i want to be vain and like
say the first one because
everybody wants to follow their dream
but you gotta get lonely
and i love my friends so i guess i would
have to give up my dream
you know school is not forever uh you
know maybe you'd make friends
in your dream school so i think i would
probably go to my dream school
and hope that my friends from home love
and support me enough to
be my friends when i come home well now
i hate my answer
so i would also say get accepted into
your dream school because it would only
be a certain amount of time would you
rather
always smell bad around the person you
like or always say something
embarrassing around the person you like
it makes me so anxious to
feel like i smell i agree with that i
feel like
smell is something that people should be
able to get past but like saying
something embarrassing
every single time you're around someone
you like they might just be like she's
weird i would rather say something
embarrassing because i could just play
it off or
you know give one of these yeah i
definitely agree i don't want to smell
bad i always have like extra deodorant
no i'll say something embarrassing also
like what's the definition of
embarrassing
it's only embarrassing it is would you
rather
only listen to the high school musical
soundtrack for the rest of your life
or only listen to the beauty and the
beast soundtrack for the rest of your
life
that's a hard one beauty and the beast
i've been listening to beauty and the
beast my whole life anyway i would say
high school musical soundtrack for me
just because i
i do that all the time i love the high
school soundtrack
that's a musical i would say high school
musical too because there's three yeah
you're right there's three high school
musical movies way more music sorry
beauty and the beast but high school
music
i'm gonna have to go with beauty and the
beast i'm gonna have to go with beauty
and the beast as well i felt like we
were gonna be on the same page with that
one
would you rather have a bad picture of
you on the cover of the school yearbook
or have a good picture of you turned
into a cardboard cutout located at the
school's entrance
um definitely cardboard cutout yeah it's
a great photo why wouldn't you want it
displayed at the front of the school so
people can be like
wow that's what a great photo is it
wasn't probably to face it though i'd
have like marked out like blacked out
seeds
both happened to me both that happened
to you
yes which one was worse the bad picture
because you know how
high schoolers are they'd be like that's
messy yeah but i also feel like it would
be
like kind of weird and awkward to have a
cardboard cut out of you at the school's
entrance no matter if it's a good or bad
picture
especially when they draw mustaches on
it and you're like
that's too much they give people too
much power i would i would rather own a
really bad photo in a yearbook than have
people
just like have a cardboard cutter to me
that would be very strange i feel pretty
bad pictures of me
been posted everywhere so i would say
i'll take the yearbook all right
i'm going with a bad picture if it's a
good picture of me
why not i can be the high school's
mascot right at the entrance
yeah why not would you rather have your
most embarrassing moment go viral on
tick tock or never be able to open
instagram ever again
sometimes i take breaks from instagram
as it is
i would be okay with never being able to
open instagram ever again
i don't know i would say have your most
embarrassing moment go viral on tick
tock because
things that go viral on tick tock last
like a
day so maybe people would just forget
about it i feel like it would end
quicker than it started hopefully never
open instagram ever i never
never opened instagram for sure that one
i would just rather do you don't even
need the other one and i'd be like
probably yeah
you never open instagram ever again
y'all are better than me
i'm addicted to instagram and looking at
spam pages that's why i'm like i need to
never be able to open it
because i i spend i spend a lot of time
scrolling on instagram
wait but now i gotta know the t what's
your most embarrassing moment first
grade uh it was my first year at a brand
new school i'd only been there for like
a month
i was in a group activity with this girl
that was always super mean to me
and um she pantsed me in front of the
entire class
all new people new school everything and
uh when i say pants i mean like like
pants like everything
but uh the teacher was like oh she's
just mean to you because she likes you
and i'm like
that's so powerful
i'm not a fan of the teacher saying she
just does that because she likes you i
don't know if that's the best stuff
yeah she was always just like well when
a girl's mean to you it's because she
likes you and i was like no
promoting toxic behavior one of the most
embarrassing ones i can think of
is when i was like nine or ten and i was
watching in a show
and my sisters were in it and like i was
sitting in the front row and i drove and
i
had an entire coke can right before the
show started and the director
yelled at me because the day before i
left to go use the restroom during the
show and he was like
wait for a blackout to go you know go
pee and i was like okay
the first 25 minutes of the show is one
scene entirely and i was just like
i'll wait for away for a blackout and i
absolutely could not and i totally
destroyed
the seat that i was sitting in and
what's funny is the next day i went to
go see the show again
and that seat was removed entirely from
the theater
so when you go to that theater now
there's literally just a seat missing
because
it's still gone to this day joshua
bassett's pee
is acid it just eats the seed away yeah
my
my most embarrassing moment um i was
hanging out with this guy and
i didn't know it was like a date or
whatever and he leans in for a kiss and
i just gave him a high five and walked
away
and so i like called him after i was
like listen i apologize
no you don't have to apologize good on
you for high fiving him and not just
like
yeah what going in for you i've been
learning something this year boundaries
they're very fun oh
i would never open instagram again i
think i wanted way too much it'd
probably be a good thing for me
yeah i completely agree i would rather
never have to be able to open up
instagram ever again yeah but you go
viral so i'm gonna i'm gonna go viral on
tick tock
would you rather spend a day without
your phone or a week with no people at
all
okay both of those actually sound kind
of appealing i'm gonna
go a week without people i'm a day
without my phone
i think i agree with you frankie i think
i would like a week with no people at
all
because i always say i'm such an
introvert but i wonder if by like
day five i would just be like i want
people like i'll be so interesting to
see
if i'm truly as introverted as i think
after 2020
i think i want to spend a day without my
phone absolutely
100 would you rather forget the name of
a person you're on a date with
or call them your ex's name by accident
oh
that's painful i think i'd be okay with
forgetting the name of a person on a
date with maybe even like especially if
it's a first date
i think that could be forgivable in the
early stages of a
relationship yeah i would have to agree
and also if i forgot somebody's name i
would just use the dara method which is
just hey queen
most definitely forget their or get
their
name
oh tell them your ex's name forgetting
someone's name
is so embarrassing because you're just
like hey man so i'd much rather just
accidentally be like oh my gosh i'm
sorry
bob i called you joe like bob and joe
i would rather forget the name because
then you can like
just avoid saying it versus if you say
someone's name you can't take that back
would you rather go on a great date with
someone you disagree about
everything with or go on a okay date
with someone you agree with about
everything
i would rather go on a great date with
somebody i disagree with i think
disagreements lead to great conversation
right it depends on yeah what do what do
we disagree on but yeah i would rather
go on an
okay date with someone that i agree with
stuff because
the next date you'll be able to do
something twice as fun that makes sense
i would say the same well it's not a
great
date if you don't agree on anything but
then that means you guys will probably
like going at it about all these
different subjects
that's true and i think opposites
attract that sounds like work i'm gonna
go on an okay date with someone
who just agrees with me thank you all so
much for having us buzzfeed and check
out high school musical the musical the
series streaming on disney plus
you